Dogs are friendly and smart.
Dogs have natural senses.
Dogs' senses help them smell, see, and hear things.
Dogs are good at doing many things that help people.
Dogs can learn to do special types of work.
Some people can't hear.
A dog can listen for sounds.
Some people can't see.
A dog helps them walk safely.
Some people can't move.
A dog can get things for them.
Some people feel sad.
A dog can make them smile.
A dog can bring home sheep that get lost.
A dog can help a hunter find wild birds.
A dog can chase geese away from airports.
A dog can smell insects that harm buildings.
A dog can help the police solve a crime.
A dog can help find out how a fire started.
A dog can sniff to find out where drugs are hidden.
A dog can jump in the water to help a swimmer.
A dog can search for people who are lost or hurt.
Dogs can learn many jobs that help people.
A dog's best work is to be a friend!